one of the at this point sort of
apocryphal refrains of insurgent
progressive left campaigns is young
people and first-time voters are going
to come out in such numbers that the
polling doesn't account for them and
thus the results are going to
drastically overperform for the
insurgent progressive candidates in
super Tuesday's case that was Bernie
Sanders this was in fact one of the big
cases for Bernie in the current primary
and there's still many primaries to go
but in order our analysis of the facts
of Super Tuesday and if people don't
like facts this is not the segment for
you it didn't happen on Super Tuesday
Bernie's young voters didn't vote they
stayed home while Joe Biden's older
voters got out and voted this shouldn't
be surprising every single election
cycle every election year the claim is
made that the insurgent progressive
candidate is going to ride high on the
unfold or at least pull support that is
not reflected in the polls from young
people and first-time voters and yet
every election cycle the same thing
happens we know the data older voters
are the most reliable voters and it
happens again and again what happened to
the young voters who could have possibly
predicted this so let's review the
numbers Bernie did really well with
young voters every prediction was right
about that sixty-one percent of voters
under 30 voted for Bernie only 17
percent of voters under 30 voted for Joe
Biden Sanders even won voters 30 to 44
years of age but those over 45 went to
Biden by large numbers and the younger
voters just don't vote as often they're
a much smaller piece of the electorate
and it's just not enough Bernie had huge
support from a huge portion of young
voters they just didn't really vote look
at Virginia as one example turnout in
Virginia doubled from 2016 okay up 100
percent this is huge but only 13 percent
of the electorate was thirty that's down
from was under 30 that's down from 16
percent of the electorate being under 30
back in 2016
there are so many more people voting and
only 13% are under 30 if you're a
candidate counting on the youth vote you
are in serious trouble North Carolina
was almost the same 13 percent of voters
were under 30 in Alabama only 7% of
voters were aged 17 to 29 if you're
going to be 18 by the time of the
November election in some states you're
allowed to vote at age 17 in Tennessee
11 percent of the electorate was under
30 that's also down from 2016 and as a
percentage of the electorate young
voters are down overall from 2016 to
2020 I don't believe the problem is
Bernie's policies ID ideas those could
do well although even when you look at
something like Medicare for all
depending on which elements of Medicare
for all you ask people about there are
different degrees of popularity and
there is no doubt that among center-left
Democrats Medicare for all in sum total
is not as popular as some of its
components but I don't believe the
problem is Bernie's policies ideas a ton
of people just didn't want to vote for
Bernie only 15 percent of black voters
went for Bernie black voters are a
really important part of the Democratic
primary electorate the young voters
showed up in smaller portions than in
2016 they love Bernie they just
apparently didn't love him enough to
actually go out and vote and that makes
it very difficult to win you can package
up Medicare for all and free college and
a progressive tax plan and a financial
transaction tax and minimum taxes for
corporations like an Amazon you can do
all that stuff but you were going to be
better off in the broader Democratic
primary electorate if you don't call
yourself a Democratic Socialist which
I've been saying for years and if you do
the packaging of those policies in a way
that will better appear appeal to older
voters and to black voters it can be
done and these are depressing numbers
I'm not telling you these numbers
because these numbers give me any
pleasure but if we pretend the numbers
don't exist we'll just never win and I
know that you know a progressive Twitter
progessive twitter is is ablaze in many
cases with defiant sort of indignance
that this is far far far from over and
what needs to happen now is not a reason
of Bernie as a candidate or of policy or
whatever but that simply this needs to
be about the DNC and the establishment
and all the stuff those are big issues
I've been talking about those issues for
years we've been talking about voter
suppression we've been talking about DNC
establishment bias all that stuff Joe
Biden got nearly a million more votes
than Bernie Sanders so far okay and you
can't if you attribute that merely to
factors that have nothing to do with
Bernie as a candidate you will never get
over the hump that clearly is a hump
that needs to be gotten over this is a
perpetual American tragedy that we're
talking about if you didn't vote you
still are voting in a sense some people
anecdotally reported not voting because
they felt their vote didn't matter or
that Bernie was bound to lose anyway
because of the DNC when you choose not
to vote it is still a vote it's a vote
for letting every other vote count more
it's a vote for letting other people
decide it's a vote for typically more of
the status quo and understand that Joe
Biden won some states after spending
essentially no time and no money there
by huge margins over Bernie that doesn't
happen just because of DNC establishment
support of Joe Biden it doesn't and the
biggest tragedy here would be if no
lessons are learned you know there's a
lesson that the center-left democratic
party needs to learn which is that
centrism in 2004 with john kerry didn't
work right in 2008 when it was a Hillary
Clinton Barack Obama rather Barack Obama
ran on progressive ideas and a more
progressive platform and he won now he
didn't end up actually governing that
way but the idea of running a more
progressive candidacy for the times in
2008 actually worked to get him elected
hillary centrist in 2016
it also didn't work that's an important
lesson for the Democratic Party to learn
the centrism stuff Republican light
doesn't work but the progressive left
also needs to learn that when you lose
the raw vote by a million simply blaming
everything but some elements of either
the candidate or the way policies are
packaged or the framing or the messaging
or the surrogates or whatever right that
there has to be some evaluation that
isn't just look at the DNC we're not
going to win either as part of the
progressive left I say that so this is
very ugly if there is ever a realization
that social media support and crowd
sizes don't win you elections it should
be this primary and there is actually a
lot to learn here and it's not all bad
if you go back and check out my video
from a month or two ago gaming out the
different possible 20/20 outcomes this
is not all bad if it's taken as an
actual learning experience and applied
to Senate races in 2020 and to 2022 and
so on and so forth I want to hear from
you what do you believe are the lessons
from what's going on so far I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman let me know quick
break more after this